[Music]
elon musk may be the superstar ceo of
spacex
but a lot of the credit goes to the guy
who was instrumental in making the
rockets
fly i'm tom mueller i'm actual founder
of the company tom mueller may not be
famous like musk but he's a big part of
the reason the company is as successful
as it is today
as vice president of propulsion and
later the propulsion chief technology
officer
he led the design testing and
construction of spacex's engines
before joining spacex mueller developed
engines at trw
a large aerospace company in los angeles
later acquired by northrup grumman
as a hobby he spent weekends testing and
flying his own machines in the mojave
desert
with an amateur rocket club called
reaction research society
that's how he met musk almost 20 years
ago through the club
the future spacex ceo had been looking
to recruit a bright team of engineers to
build rockets
the year before musk had gone to moscow
to try to buy refurbished icbms
but when the russians wanted too much
money he set out to build his own rocket
for less so when it came time to
founding spacex
musk saw mueller someone who knew
everything there was to know about
rocket engines
when i met elon it's like wow i'd really
like to go do this thing it's
high risk it's where i want to be going
to a startup was risky but also gave him
free reign to do more
mueller is known for developing rocket
engines from scratch
including the merlin engine this is a 95
000 pound thrust engine basically this
engine will burn a hole right through
concrete
these engines power the falcon line of
rockets the 27 in the falcon heavy
generate over 5 million pounds of thrust
at liftoff and the falcon 9 gets its
name from the nine merlin engines in the
first stage
they're fueled by rocket-grade kerosene
and liquid oxygen
it's not easy developing an engine that
can withstand a 170 second burn
long enough to send a payload into orbit
and then returned safely
to earth merlin revolutionized space
flight as it's designed to be reused
building reusable rockets put spacex on
the map
it's now a common sight to see the
falcon 9 first stage perform one of its
signature landings last year
that rocket launched astronauts aboard
the crew dragon to the international
space station
mueller also developed the engines that
helped the dragon spacecraft maneuver
while in orbit
well before these achievements mueller
was right beside musk
during the company's most difficult days
when attempts to launch its first rocket
the falcon 1 kept failing
the third time it tried to fly into
orbit the first stage rear-ended the
second
caused by a small amount of residual
thrust from the first stage after the
engine was cut off
spacex had enough money to scrounge up a
fourth in what would have been
final flight if it failed this time the
team told the rocket to wait a few more
seconds after the engine was cut off
before stage separation
fourth time's a charm
the falcon 1 became the first privately
developed liquid fuel rocket to orbit
the planet
which led to a billion dollar contract
with nasa that saved the company
mueller has been an integral part of the
story of spacex from the start
but he almost never became an engineer
if it were not for some sage
advice as the son of a logging truck
driver raised in a small town in idaho
being an engineer wasn't something he
considered he wanted to be an aircraft
mechanic
then i took a math class when i was a
freshman in high school
and my math teacher said to me do you
want to be the guy
that fixes a plane or the guy that
designs the plane
that was a pivotal point of my life of
course i wanted to be the guy
that designs the plane no one had told
me that i had the aptitude to be an
engineer
i didn't even know what an engineer did
that teacher changed my life he spent
summers logging to pay his way through
college
studying mechanical engineering at the
university of idaho
after graduation he set out for
california in its thriving aerospace
industry
but instead of finding a job designing
planes he wanted to work on his
childhood passion
rockets i realized that was a key
decision
a fork in the road where i made the
right choice to do what i love
don't settle put yourself on the right
path and end up where you want to be
after a storied career at spacex he
stepped back into a part-time advisory
role in 2016
as musk in the propulsion department led
the development of new engines
for a new rocket
this could be the first engine to take
people to mars raptor engines power
spacex's fully reusable rocket
starship they're fueled by liquid oxygen
and liquid methane
methane could possibly be made on the
red planet for the journey home
as spacex soars to new heights much of
its achievements can be traced back to
the early work of tom mueller
in fact musk acknowledged his
contributions were critical to spacex's
success
the man who helped make the rockets fly
officially retired in late 2020
capping off a nearly two decade career
at spacex which has been in his words
quite a ride ability plus luck equals
success if you have the ability then
luck
is your opportunity mueller may have met
the right visionary at the right
time but it took more than luck to win
musk over
a great engineer requires a solid
background in math
science and computer science whether
you'd like to brush up on the math you
learned as an undergrad
want to take a programming or simply
wish to expand your critical thinking
through logic courses
you can sign up for free with brilliant
brilliant offers over 60
interactive courses there are no tests
and if you happen to answer incorrectly
my sponsor brilliant explains where you
went wrong you can register with the
link in my description
and the first 200 people to use my link
will get 20
off the premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all the courses
thanks so much for watching for news
think i'm cindy palm